il est 17h30 maeva s'apprête à prendre
son service
parti pour une très longue nuit bye bye
va être hôtesse de l'air depuis sept ans
trois heures avant le décollage
elle rejoint le reste de l'équipage dans
cette annexe de la compagnie air austral
à quelques centaines de mètres de
l'aéroport roland garros
ce soir ils seront 13 à bord on les
appelle les pnc personnels navigant
commercial 10 hôtesses et 3 stewards
pendant qu'à côté le commandant de bord
et des deux copilotes prépare le plan de
vol
antoinette la chef de cabine principale
annonce les prévisions passagers 68 ans
glasgow un quota de 400 passagers il est
19h15
l'équipage prend la direction de
l'aéroport
il reste maintenant moins d'une heure
avant le décollage maintenant on va
faire notre sécurité
juste avant le vol
c'est parti
pendant que les hôtesses inspectent les
moindres recoins
romain compte les plateaux repas
ça s'appelle comment stands rossi
apparemment personne ne sait que gallet
est un mot anglais qui signifie cuisines
de bord
à l'avant de l'appareil dans le cockpit
le commandant de bord et son copilote
eux vérifient l'ensemble des commandes
mais ces dames et dernier avant alain
portes 12 maeva à la charge d'accueillir
près de 200 passages 200 fois répété le
même bonsoir les mêmes formules de
bienvenue trente minutes plus tard mardi
merci lp n'est terrorisés manque encore
de sécurité étaient groupés situés de
chaque côté de la cabine sont signalés
partout
en cas d'urgence
20h30 l'avion décolle saint-denis
s'éloigne dans la nuit pour l'équipage
commence alors le très long service de
ce restaurant volant de 419
le centre de plasil urbain de fès
le tapis de sol
maeva est affecté à la classe confort le
champagne est au frais les plats
gastronomiques sont en supplément
jeudi
pour ce caviar de la mer caspienne ce
passager père à 35 euros
[Musique]
on a maintenant sa cavalcade
là c'est calme et on va
[Musique]
à l'abri des regards hôtesses et
stewards dean rapidement
[Musique]
l'avion survole à présent l'afrique les
passagers s'assoupissent ou font leur
cinéma
pour la première fois depuis le
décollage il ya deux heures maeva a le
temps de se confier un peu
hôtesse de l'air c'était un rêve de
petite fille
qu'est ce qui te faisait rêver
vous voyez
[Musique]
que la réalité c'est ça c'est quand même
un peu plus difficile
là comme certains
c'est l'inconvénient
[Musique]
à bord il faut notamment gérer les
passagers indélicat ou ceux qui
exagèrent avec la boisson
et si un passager abuse avec l'alcool on
passe la consigne de ne plus lui servir
à boire
c'est parfois compliqué à gérer
ça dépend
il faut aussi gérer les malaises
[Musique]
le passager a été amené à l'arrière de
l'appareil
maeva contrôle à présent sa glycémie
ça fait beaucoup
[Musique]
succès
quelques instants plus tard une médecin
se présente et livres rapidement un
techno stick rassurant
[Musique]
et pendant toute la nuit les incidents
et les tâches routinières ce succès est
ainsi quasiment sans arrêt
twente ricardo
[Musique]
quand tu es genre qui fait pas
maeva nous emmène à présent vers un
endroit où les passagers ne vont jamais
par un escalier secret on accède au
couchettes ou les membres d'équipage se
repose à tour de rôle pas se reposer
deux heures et demie
nicker quoi ça peut partir jusqu'à 3
heures oui
c'est l'heure
vous arrivez à vous entendre bien
facilement
dix minutes oui en général on tombe
merci beaucoup à tout à l'heure
je
quand maeva se réveille c'est déjà
l'heure du café
[Musique]
j'ai bien dormi
utilise que l'hôtesse de l'air
finalement ce n'est faire le serveuse
pas du tout
on est inquiet affirme et policiers
serveuse
il faut être sans arrêt
trop capable de s'adapter à n'importe
quelle situation
mesdames et messieurs notre atterrissage
est proche
super 8 yeoh
on est à paris
dans trois journées à la réunion
moi je puisse faire
[Musique]
le soleil n'est pas encore levé sur
paris après onze heures de vol sans
encombre
le boeing se pose à roissy charles de
gaulle
bonjour
il fait bon chez vous c'est bon on peut
débarquer merci beaucoup
madame il ne reste plus qu'à dire 200
fois
au revoir
[Musique]
maeva maintenant droit à deux jours de
repos une nuit à paris et demain soir en
remet ça dans l'autre sens
au revoir ouais